thank you the ambassador is therefore
indeed first hello to all
you have noted it even the ambassador
is indeed my my second
day and I am very very happy to
start the work and within the
art commission  by this council that was
held so this morning you recalled the
main elements that were decided
share I had referred to return
I take the other that you indicated
it was not exactly the order of our
debates d  First of all the debate that was
held, you obviously recalled it
under the Finnish presidency of course,
but with Minister Kouassi who
therefore agreed to lead our debates and
therefore ultimately we have a situation which
was which was interesting since
on the one hand obviously  he completely
embraced the very significant advances
of the Finnish presidency, but
they were also there and it was by
chance in being soon the one very
soon in a few weeks the one who
will have chaired  this advice in the context of
the Croatian presence of data so
finally interesting exchanges
because on the one hand we were obviously able to
take stock of the pre-national of her
and I would like to tell you this,
Madam Ambassador, the unanimous advice to
salute the progress and the energy with
which you have worked on these
subjects in the interest of the union
and then of course we are also
planning a little more on the
coming semester because we have of course a
lot of work and  in particular on this
essential subject for the union for our
companies and for our fellow citizens
I therefore take the subjects such as
you mentioned in the order that you
mentioned 5g is a subject which was
important there were conclusions
which  been made important work
that has been done that I welcomed that when
I became aware is obviously
very important
and I would just like to say two elements
that seem to me to synthesize this
work first t  everyone
obviously sees the importance of 5g for
the deployment and competitiveness of
our companies
throughout Europe,
even if I underlined it,
5g technology is a bit special, it will allow us in
particular to develop
applications  news and numerous
in the fashion in the industrial world
in the industry to give it and
in particular in all that is called the internet
of objects of haiti I spoke about it it is
an absolutely essential subject that we
have to deal with  on
industrial data 5g will allow us
precisely this deployment in
factories in supermarkets in
hospitals everywhere in fact and continues the
specificity of 5g
it will be rather developed in
corridors in denser places
since as you know it is necessary  a
multitude of antennas much more than
for 4g or 3g
we are not at all in the same
frequency ranges and therefore it requires a
very  s specific content
once again specificity which
also obviously gives the counterpart
it is much more numerous access points
to the network and therefore the
cybersecurity and security aspect on 5g
and perhaps much more critical than
in technologies  previous ones
since once again we are going to have a
multitude of deployment of antennas
much more important I repeat and
micro antennas when we the specificity
of this technology and obviously that
allowed us to take
stock first by noting one thing and by
as commissioner for the internal market
obviously in charge of industry with
three directorates general who
report to me i would like to say what i
recalled earlier that europe
is not behind in terms of 5g
canton  contrary to what we can
read here or where to tell you it is not
true, Europe today has
major industrial players and Europe
which arises through these
industrial players from  u largest portfolio
of patents in the 5g field more than 55%
of 5g patents are original and
owned by European companies
I say this because we sometimes read
things that are a little bit different
so it's good to  remember it then
it is true that behind there are two
aspects which were mentioned in the
context of the deployment
after having recalled the importance of this
deployment the first is obviously to
guarantee good competition to
compete
obviously of course on the
European territory of  actors who would allow the
deployment of 5 g infrastructures that
are not European
and there of course we have rules
which must be true that it was
very broadly and very explicitly
indicated in the report
we must ensure that  these rules are
quite simply compatible with those of the
market one obviously keeps the
problems of reciprocity you have to
look at the problems of subsidies in
fact all these questions which are
questions  you know well,
you obviously have to look at them on
this technology as on others,
but since we are talking about this one, it is
one of the elements that appear in the
report, which of course we will look at,
as for all the rest,
the  second element that has been specified
that allows me to make the connection with
what I told you earlier about
the somewhat specific technology of
5g and its particular mode of
deployment is obviously the aspects
of security and  cybersecurity
in other words in a 5g deployment
why do we talk a lot more about
security than talking about it in the
past because once again we have a
multitude of access points
that require so it has been seen
again  once in the work
that was presented to us this morning which therefore does not give
rise to a good look at what is
happening in terms of
equipment safety so it is obviously the
responsibility of the states for the moment
and therefore they  we have an
agency that helps them
I said the quality is there if there is a network
the coordination of networks at the silo
obviously does the commission makes
available to the member states its agency
its know-how its know-how
the apparatus obviously belongs to the
states is precisely to ensure
that the security of its infrastructures
is ensured
so there the work has been indicated there are
technical subjects to be looked at
a little more in depth from the rsa but they have
been well identified they must be
deepened and is what  we said
is that basically given the
specificity of this
technology still is obviously due to the fact that
we are
all interconnected so it is
necessary that the commission can
know precisely this role without
coordination supervision that we
take had willingly du  remains in order to be
able to help precisely in this
somewhat critical phase of the deployment
so here I am basically summarizing what was
said on the  hand on 5g
we then talked about the weee
privacy directive so each member state
expressed itself obviously we could see the
chairman of the session even obviously
that there were obviously still
some differences on this question
a certain number of states  members
showed their impatience
some told us we've been working on it for three years
others told us but basically we are
now applying a directive
dating from 2002 2002 it's almost a
generation almost 20 years
it takes  obviously work in particular on
everything that is worth at tt over the top 1
that we really have to work on all
these new ones what a new
platform brings in this area which is
essential all the same for 511 million
of our fellow citizens who live every
day  in this environment
so I felt interviewed with the
chairman of the session and future president
in office I felt for some
members perhaps a
frustration others an impa  to find
a solution and here as elsewhere
I therefore first expressed the
will of the commission and myself my
availability to go and see
each other
try you reminded it
Madam Ambassador I am here  for two
days therefore
and if the 2 have been able to perceive well understand
the different shows and express but
because they are really deep
in ascq employment is understandable when finding
a consensus it requires on my part and
I tell him clearly in a model session
to see them again  maybe each
other to see obviously where we are
and then obviously it will be up to the
president who she is so it's
interesting because we were talking
both about the past and we were also talking about
the future and so I  share it with my
of my volunteers years for obviously he
is in this dance is up to you this
approach go see all the member states
here see it then because the
president will of course
also discuss with the p  Parliament because
parliament is very much associated on
this issue there is a lot of work
that has been done and then the president
will decide but depending on what he
decides all the options will be put
on the table obviously it's normal a
lot of members  expressed the
need
perhaps to go perhaps a
little faster
three years is a long time and it will
certainly be one of the tasks of the
next Croatian President who was here
this morning to respond to this
legitimate question on the part of our
fellow citizens we spoke then
you reminded us of the
cybersecurity center consensus is very there on the
other hand broad consensus and total
consensus on the need to create this
skills center reminds us of this
set of behaviors in is  simple it
is both in r&d and in
technology which will also have a capacity
to promote investment in the
case of existing programs and it is
important
and then to define technologies  These
are key technologies in
which we are going to invest, but from start
to finish also to coordinate a little
more the activities of the member states in
terms of cybersecurity internal coordination
is extremely important in
terms of cybersecurity as
soon as we have information about convoys
something that appears in a
member state on a system in an
emigration
you obviously have to be able to share it
immediately to be able to first
understand what is happening and then
also protect yourself from threats that could
then be deduced from it or be duplicated
by others  so coordination in terms
of cybersecurity is an
absolutely essential element it will also be one of the
missions of those of this center but
a broad consensus to
finally contribute to this 2025 ambition which
had been reminded at the ats in tallinn
I was  moreover at the time
in other functions it was in 2017 by the
heads of state if they had met
the government then  s that they had
met to ensure that in 2025
the union is clearly identified as
an undisputed and indisputable leader
in cybersecurity
here I roughly summarize what was
said with my words that this complement
you  a little bit but obviously
without deviating one iota from
what you have just said m
the ambassador thank you